[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
make sure you're not showing credentials
of anybody
thank you so much
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
describe the western conference in one
word uh for us right now it's a cluster
second word final week of the
regular season uh playoffs are right
around the corner
teams are fighting to secure their
seating spots you know
some teams are having to fight a little
harder than others right now so it's
gonna be an eventful week as we
figure out how things shake out and we
get a better view of this playoff
picture
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
hey jim so is there like a different
level of locking in you know here
there's no distractions you're in
orlando it's really just basketball how
does that make me change how focused you
can be
i think everybody's like you know
there's no distractions there's no fans
there's no family
uh it's literally in the gym and you're
in the hotel with your team you know
behind me
okay so the lakers have already clinched
number one seed in the playoffs tonight
they pay the thunder who are still
fighting
it's going to be a good one playoffs are
right around the corner
so chris just like what do you tell the
guys about
playoffs uh they probably get tired of
me talking about it
i'm dancing they're probably getting
tired of me talking because
one of the things you learn about
playoffs and
what every team is trying to build even
in the regular season is you want to
make sure that you have a team that
feels like they can't be
can't be beat four out of seven times
right so the best teams know that you
can be beat
on a tuesday night in january or on a
thursday night in july you know but they
know that they can't be
beat four out of seven times so we're
just trying to build that identity
and get ready
[Applause]
saturday august 8th i am headed to the
memphis grizzlies practice
grizzlies having a hard time here i've
seen no justice winslow
no jaren jackson jr but they have john
moran who today was actually named as a
rookie of the year finalist
gonna go watch practice maybe talk to
him but
it's definitely a an upward battle and
an uphill battle for the grizzlies to
be in the playoffs
[Music]
how are you i'm all good
okay so obviously you guys unfortunately
have had a lot of injuries on the scene
a bit of an uphill battle
how do you just kind of stay in it keep
your mind right like it's not really i
feel like we all have that
you know next man up mentality so um
i mean we all heard that we lost you
know um some players
uh due to the injuries um wish them a
speedy recovery but um
i mean we got we have to play with what
we have um
i'm very confident in all our players
okay so with playoffs right around the
corner great players are stepping up to
give their teams that final push two of
those players
devin booker tj warren we're at the
pacers game right now watching the tj
warren show
okay in the third i call the
[Music]
111 pacers indiana i'm gonna be right
[Music]
lakers
devin booker has been an nba bubble
all-star okay right now he is just
really leading the sons
phoenix is undefeated in the bubble
heading into the final week
largely in part to devin booker he's
been such an exciting player to watch
i'm running late to go watch him so uh
let's do it
let's go if i can get my mask on okay
come on let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are the phoenix suns being very
loud
only undefeated team left in the bubble
hey devon first off nice honey
uh exactly what do you think that nba
fans like thought about the suns before
the bubble
and what do they think about the sun now
um
i mean you'd have to ask around um
you know we said coming into this that
you know we're fine with being
underrated our team
that's so far so good so you got the
right approach i keep saying approach
every interview i do
because the day we got down here
you know just as sharp as we've been
all right thank you for your time
monday august 10th headed to watch the
indiana pacers take on the miami heat
but it's really jimmy butler versus tj
warren gonna be a showdown baby
[Music]
bye
okay so here's our jimmy butler tj
warren updates
a lot of switching happening it's not
even that like jimmy
and tj are going out at the whole time
we might have blown up
this entire thing
[Music]
[Music]
illinois trash
illini's trash listen how are you going
first up did y'all change the name of
y'all arena yet
yeah they stole our name no where
they're real
so we're not in something else anymore
yeah you know why they
[Music]
our school has been around longer they
need to hear this too our school has
been around longer
it just feels better in there
that's why they had to change the name
he's wrong so let me tell you this i
have known victor for
years met him when i was in illinois and
he was in indiana
when i was roaming the real assembly
hall in champaign illinois
lakers nuggets tonight should be a
another great match up
teams looking to finish strong and build
some winning habits as we head into the
postseason
[Music]
on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10 being
playoff ready
where are you guys i don't know i don't
think we're at ten
and we shouldn't be a tent because it's
a different type of preparation that
goes into a playoff game
me personally as far as mentally i'm not
in playoff mode um physically i'm
getting there i feel like my legs are
gotten better and better my game doesn't
pull more and more i'm getting more and
more comfortable with
the bubble um but as far as the the
mental
side of it um no i'm not their
personality
our team is their personal but we will
be
and with that shot i have to ask
obviously we say we see
the secret stuff tattoo what's in your
secret stuff i can't tell you
if i tell you that's not a secret
[Applause]
classy
thursday august 13th incredibly
important day in the bubble
today the suns have to beat the
mavericks
and the blazers or grizzlies have to
lose
in order for them to make the play-in
tournament for the blazers
all the blazers have to do is beat the
nets
and they are in so a lot is riding
on that eighth spot today these games
are crucial
i can't wait
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
cameroon
the phoenix suns have officially gone
undefeated in the bubble a lot
is riding on tonight they need the nets
to beat the blazers if they want to make
the plane
really quickly i just wanted them to
know how much i love them and how much i
appreciated
them allowing me to be a part of a
special
period franchise
i'm sure we'll get together and watch um
brooklyn portland day anybody ever
complained it's always competitive
there's a lot of trash talking practices
all for this i mean this birthday we're
walking
party
[Applause]
my
[Music]
[Music]
because everybody don't laugh at me yeah
oh that's hilarious i love it
[Music]
[Music]
blazers fighting for their life
[Music]
okay
okay going into the fourth quarter next
104 blazers 97.
paris lavert has 28 points he has taken
over
i don't know fourth quarter might be
game time or
this might be it for the blazers
[Music]
i am so stressed watching this game like
do i want the sun
it's a good story do i want to watch
dane he's so good and he's exciting like
i am stressed out
[Applause]
that was insane
and you talked about it most people have
never been in
what is the best comparison to how it
feels out there
[Music]
i mean when i was in college i never
i never made it to the ncaa tournament
but once we got to
our conference tournament like
everything that you did
in the regular season now it's like it's
a small conference only one team goes to
attack
so if you lose in the tournament you go
home
and there's no chance you're getting a
bit to the tournament and that's kind of
how it felt for me it was like
you have to win tonight
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the bubble has ended for john moran such
a young promising star i asked him the
thing that's going to stick out to him
the most
in his rookie season and his answer
actually made me kind of sad
hey uh
you